hey guys it's the first of February my
name is Jeff and you're watching games
funny bus stop new details on the
Nintendo switches online service have
emerged industry analyst second Toto
iterated that nintendo president
atsumichi Mishima indicated to
publication Nikkei that the online
service will cost between 2000 and 3000
yen annually which translates to around
18 to 27 US dollars while this might not
be the exact u.s. price this does put
the Nintendo switches online service
cost far below Xbox Live Gold and
PlayStation Plus which tend to run you
60 bucks a year Nintendo had previously
revealed that the service will
facilitate online multiplayer and will
give users access to a free NES or SNES
game each month however access to these
games is limited to a single month the
online service will kick off with a free
trial at the switch is launched with the
paid version expected sometime in the
fall of 2017
next up final fantasy 15 may be coming
to piece 8 in an interview with Tim itsu
game director Hajime Tabata said I'd
like to release the game on PC as a
technical attempt I want to show PC uses
Final Fantasy 15 running on high-end
machines he also talked about exploring
the possibility of PC exclusive features
such as custom quests and mods elsewhere
in the interview Tabata commented on the
possibility of remaking playable areas
in future expansions but due to the
amount of time required it is not
currently in their plans he said a for
argument's sake if we were to prepare
new fields insomnia would also be a
candidate but that also would take a
year's worth of work
finally some free stuff for your
Wednesday s PlayStation Plus is febri
games have been announced this month
there are 5 ps4 games up for grabs
including a little big planet 3 not a
hero a star wall and ninja Thank You GX
and talk l yes 3 users can pick up an
extended edition and star wall while
ninja Sankey DX and took l are available
for PlayStation Vita these games should
be arriving with the next PlayStation
update on February 7 in the meantime be
sure to pick up January's free games
while he still can't that is everything
I have for you today do head to GameSpot
for stories on dirt 4 and Star Wars
Battlefront and I'll see you tomorrow